okay hi everyone welcome to this video
on the power of the price
rejector this is a market recap for June
27 to July 1st 2016 my name is Michael
Vos I'm the founder and Trader at
orderflows decom first a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a Sol
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures Trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future
results okay so this is the orderflows
trader chart and what I'm going to
really focus on today is using the
orderflows trader chart in combination
with the price rejector the orderflows
trader chart is a footprint chart the
price rejector is an indicator that will
help you pick swing highs and swing lows
in the order flow this is a sell this is
a
buy when you have the red hash it
indicates a sell this area up here um
you know the hash will appear as soon as
the in the indicator conditions are met
now if it changes in the bar it'll
disappear but once it's drawn it will
not redraw so once the bar closes and
it's there it's there okay it's not
going to change now again this is an
orderflows indicator so it works in real
times if you load a chart load the
indicator it won't go over the past
history because it's reading the data as
it comes in if you want to see how it
performed over a certain period then
just you know it runs on ninja Trader
ninja Trader has a nice Market replay
function where you can as long as you
your computer was open and you're saving
the data you can run it in Market replay
and it'll read the data as it's coming
in
just as it did during the market hours
so keep that in mind you know if you're
going to get the indicator and load it
on your system and say hey I don't have
any signals well the reason you don't
have any signals is because it needs a
data be be coming in
fresh and read it that way as opposed to
you know reading the the previous data
it runs on ninja Trader 7 the ninja
Trader 8 version should be coming out in
a few weeks time but right now you know
I'm still using ninja Trader 7 that's
why I'm focusing on ninja Trader 7 ninja
Trader 8 is available still in beta and
you know once it comes out officially in
beta then you'll will get everything
switched over and any upgrades that
ninja Trader 8 will be free of charge so
what's orderflow well orderflow is a way
to analyze the market based on trades
being executed on the bid and the offer
as well as the volume and you can see
here these are the volumes on the bid
these are the volumes on the offer and
what you want to do is you want to
analyze that as well as the volume not
all prices are the same know if all
prices are the same the market wouldn't
move okay when I say not all prices are
the same what I mean is you know there's
different levels of participation and
different types of participation there's
aggressive buying there's aggressive
selling you know there's there's price
support there's price resistance I mean
what causes a market to turn you know is
is what happens at certain price levels
in in terms of the participation at
those
levels what is the price rejector it's
an indicator based on order flow
analysis to determine when the last
buyer has bought and the last seller has
sold right so you know if you're looking
for a reversal you have to have a move
that's going to reverse it you know if
you're going to be sitting here trading
inside a range like you're seeing here
yeah the market did go up you're not
getting any signals here you you know
you got it earlier here then the market
went sideways and then went up but if
the market is trading sideways generally
you're not going to get any any signals
I mean what you want to do right you
want to catch ends of moves and
beginnings of new moves is ideally what
you want to do I mean you're not going
to you know it's going to be hard to
make money when the market is just
trading sideways like this you know if
you took the signal here this is 929 and
you're just sitting in here going back
and forth you're thinking oh Jesus you
know this is the worst indicator ever
we're not moving and then then it pops
up you know ideally what you like is you
know you get the signal here then boom
you get the nice a nice selloff but you
know you can only do what the Market's
going to give
you so you know the order flows Trader
and price rejector software runs on the
ninj trader
platform you can go to the website www.
ninjatrader dcom and you can download a
copy of the software it's free it's easy
to use and you know for the order flows
Trader and the price rejector you just
import it right into ninja Trader and
trade it's
designed ideally the price rejector is
designed for an orderflows Trader chart
you don't need okay how specify you
don't need the order flows Trader chart
although you know I recommend it I mean
yes it is my software people will say
well you put out these videos you know
but you have to buy your software
well you want to drive you got to buy a
car but we've also programmed the price
rejector to run on a normal bar chart so
if you don't want to deal with an you
know a footprint chart you can just run
it on a normal bar chart although you
know I do recommend using a footprint
chart and ideally I do recommend using
my orderflows Trader chart because you
know I I take a foot print chart to the
next level you know and I have ways you
know simple ways that show you how you
can understand the order flow better I
mean you could have a footprint chart
but if you don't know what you're
looking at then what's the
point so again you know there's no PhD
needed on this it's not rocket science
but there is a science to it and you
know you don't need a live trading room
to sit there and learn this it's really
very simple to use so you know let's
look at you know I like to show how it
how it performs over time rather than
just chry pick a chart here and there
and show you the best chart and say this
is how it works every time because you
know what there's winners there's losers
okay and you know I want you to I'm try
to be up front so you can see that and
you can
understand you know what what sort of
potential profit potentials or or losses
you're going to be looking at on on
trades so let's get started okay so this
is uh June 27 it's Monday you know I
started my charts a little bit late here
it's 9:29 in the morning okay yeah you
got a buy here we'll disregard this buy
for now Market goes up here boom you get
a sell okay now you know I won't get
into the ratios because you know it's an
added feature of the orderflows trader
chart but what I want you to see is is
how it's How just the price rejector is
working you know when there's something
with the orderflows trader chart I will
also uh I'll also highlight it okay so
you know it gives you a sell here now
again it's you're not getting short
right at this high this is indicating at
the top of the bar you know yeah I could
have had it drawn down here but you know
I like to draw it on on the top and just
as The Bu will appear on the bottom so
as soon as you know the conditions are
met it will show up if the conditions in
that bar change it will disappear I mean
if it changes that conditions are not
met then it will disappear it will stay
there as long as the conditions are met
then once the bar closes it'll print
it'll stay there and it won't come off
okay so it's not going to change you
know if we take out and make a new high
or anything like that once it draws it's
drawn there it doesn't change on your
chart okay so you but know that said you
if you close your charts down you know
whatever has been drawn will disappear
when you reopen your
charts okay so this was a nice you know
a nice short so don't think you're
getting short right at the top of this
bar you're getting short in in the next
bar you or even if you're aggressive you
get short towards the end of the bar
this is a four range e mini chart
okay people use different chart time
frames that's fine you know it works
with all sorts I'll try and show you
another chart later that's maybe you
know not not what you're used to looking
at okay so this was a sell this was a
buy you know here and you know Market
went up here's a sell another
sell and Market came off you know this
one I like a lot more because it's got a
ratio you know my ratios yeah I use I
talk about ratios in the order flow
whenever you get a ratio it's a good
thing has a potential short but when
it's working when you work it with the
price rejector I think it's it's uh even
better okay here's a
buy you know this one failed a couple
more buys these these failed pretty
quick you know so you're not sitting
there going sideways and waiting for it
to you know for it to to work or not you
know it's either going to give you a a
good trade or or a bad
trade okay see anything up here nothing
you know this is the the Monday after
the brexit vote okay so it's Market was
kind of uh kind of all over the place
here's a nice buy
boom you know what sort of risk are you
going to be having on trade well if
you're getting long here you know the
reason why we have it you know price is
the indicator drawn on the bottom is
because if we get below this we violate
this low price then there's no more
reason to be in the trade so that's why
it's drawn on on the low here yeah I
probably could have had it drawn on the
next one but I much rather have it you
know the entry signal appearing you know
as soon as it happens but you know if
you're getting long here as soon as this
bar closes and the next Bar opens you
know your risk is just down to here it's
basically the risk of this bar you know
plus a tick so you know even if you want
to finesse your entry yeah you could
even throw a bid in somewhere you know
in the body of this bar ideally at the
point of control but you know often
times you know points of control act as
support or resistance so it may trade
there and then bounce up so you know
somewhere inside the body of the bars a
good entry a little bit better than just
getting long you know or getting short
right as soon as the next Bar opens but
your stop is pretty well defined it's
just outside of this this line
here you know so you know you're talking
right you had those few okay here right
you're getting long you know 1991 and a
half yeah the market you know trades up
to the 95 96 level but you're only
risking one bar right how many bars up
is that six seven seven bars I mean you
know earlier right we had these losses
boom boom boom right in a row you know
people will say oh you know this this
indicator sucks
because uh you know it had those losses
you know right in a row where is it here
okay you know this one started out and
it failed this one failed now sometimes
when you're trying to find a low a swing
low the Market's got other ideas and
it's going to go lower okay so boom boom
boom you know these are also divergences
you know you got positive Deltas on the
new lows I mean it looked like the these
are going to the lows but you know what
your your stop is you have a stop you
have to use a stop you know and you know
you're not risking very much you're
risking basically you know one bar maybe
over a bar maybe even less than a bar if
you're trying to get a better entry and
work somewhere in the body of you know
the previous bar of the you know entry
bar so you know say you're trying to get
in here or here you know you're
basically only risking one point so
would you risk you know one point you
know trying to
catch yeah where is that one trying to
catch a nice move you know that's uh you
know how many
points like here yeah you know you're
risking that one point you know and
you're getting you know Five Points
returned you don't have to be right
every single time you know yeah it sucks
when you get two or three losers in a
row here's another one boom okay this
one's not going to give you that second
chance or that you know if you're trying
to financee your entry it's not going to
give it to you you really got to get in
at the end and then you know it from 93
up to 95 you get a sell signal right
here in this bar so you know you're
getting somewhere short around 4 and A2
Market trades right up to the top there
you know it's the price rejector is
telling you that these levels are being
rejected you know the levels above this
area are being rejected just as the
prices below here are being
rejected okay this one just went
sideways yeah it started to make its
move but you know it just sort of went
sideways and again you know if you're
sitting this trade for you know 10
minutes and it's not going anywhere you
should be thinking getting out I mean
don't think you're going to be holding
the trade for you know 30 minutes
waiting for it to go into your favor
yeah here's a here's a sell okay and you
again it trades from you know what is
that the 90 level down to 88 87 and a
half here's a
buy and this one didn't really work out
it started to came down you know went
through it by a tick boom then we still
looking for its low you know it's still
looking for the low you know this one
any better yeah this one worked out you
know 852 up to you know 87 you could to
sell this one didn't work time is it now
it's
2:00 yeah this one started to you know I
don't know if you could have gotten you
you could have got something out of it
you know
89 90 maybe a point but still I'm not
just looking for a point only yeah this
one didn't work this one did
nicely you you're talking from 86 and a
half up to you know the 90
area okay where are we we coming up on
3:00 here okay here's a nice cell right
here it's two it's 240 boom you know and
then you're getting short somewhere
around here 93 down to the 90s then you
get a buy and you shoot right back up to
those
levels okay coming at 3:00 here cash
closes
3:00 okay then nothing for the rest of
that day let's look at the next day okay
this is the next day uh 28 8 of June
Tuesday things have things calmed down a
bit you know after that brexit vote so
you know 8:20 you get a buy here yeah
got through it by a tick uh you know
then gone up you know again if you're
using a one tick stop you'd be stopped
out if you're using the two tick stop
you'd still be in the trade um it's up
to you this one didn't work out this one
failed now this is right after the cash
open yeah you had you had a ratio there
didn't work out uh where are we here
nothing nothing here's a
buy this was interesting you got you got
the nice big imbalance there 1,600 you
know it started to work and it just went
sideways on you again you know you're
you're in the trade at 9 you know 10
after 9 9913 what is that sorry
9:16 you know and you're holding it into
this area it's not working out you know
after you know at what point are you
going to get out you know you going to
let it go to your stop price or you
going to manage the trade and get
out uh you know this was a buy that
failed this one yeah we broke through it
by a tick you know then
rops fail
fail oh but you know I I want you to see
this you sure there's some failures you
know this was a decent one you know 9
and 1/2 up to 11 and a
half you what we do we came right back
down to that level before popping back
up
again this day this Market took off very
strongly late in the day if you
remember so was a sell this was late
this one failed
okay so that was it you know there's
some winners there were some losers you
know but if you're only risking a point
and but you're getting you
know two three points out of a out of a
winner know you don't need
50/50 okay this is uh the 29th Wednesday
yeah 6:00 in the morning there was a buy
Here 6:20 you it did pop up a little bit
came down probably would have stopped
out you know when when I see it come up
like this and it hits a ratio a number
you know in my order flows Trad
you know I know I'll be fighting it if
I'm going to be expecting the market to
keep going up so it's usually a signed
to me to get out if you know once I'm
long I get something in the orderflow
tell me to get out I mean you know I
mean that's what you you know when
you're trading and and things change in
the
market then you have to get out I mean
don't stay in in the trade if you know
the Market's telling you that hey it's
time to get
out that's the difference between a good
Trader you know a winning Trader and a
losing Trader losing Traders don't know
when to get out when Trader
do okay this was sort of a bad quote
here but then you know we got this Buy
Signal here 823 you know we've shot up
nice a nice move up here's another
buy you know this one went up you know I
remember this day I had some very bad
connections I think some of my quotes
were messed
up you know a couple buys
here shot up you another another buy
there you know it shot up
what do we got here anything
nothing this was a buy that
failed yeah I mean there's going to be
days where you have some you know a lot
of good trades and then days you have
some losers this was a
sell you know just show one sideways on
you
this was a sell that
failed and that was the end of the
day okay so moving on to June 30th again
6: in the morning I don't know if you
want to be trading at that time I mean I
I start to look at the market at 6 I
really I think the volume really starts
I volume is decent starting at 2: a.m.
when Europe opens but you know 6:00 a.m.
7:00 a.m. is really the time I I really
start paying attention to what's
happening in the S&S so you mean this
was a buy here at 6:00 a.m. you it went
sideways and
failed uh okay now we're coming into
what time is it here 740 this sell it
failed you know it's still looking for
its high here it's high area we got
through you know we got a ratio which is
you know something that I like you the
blue number here um it didn't work out I
said still looking for that high okay
and here we finally hit that high you
off times you know I would love to have
that one indicator that can find the
high every single time but you know what
that indicator doesn't exist sometimes
the market is still searching for that
high so here you know we fail here fail
here boom it won so you know you lose a
point lose a
point and you know here you get it all
back this was a cell you know kind of
worked out kind of moving around pretty
quick there a lot of imbalances
here's a buy boom straight up here's a
sell kind of going sideways a little bit
lower finally it falls over to another
buy you know the market shot right up
here's a sell this one failed you know
you had what did you have you had nice
winner nice winner nice winner nice
winner you then a loser you had a couple
losers earlier but you know what these
winners are are making up for it are
making up for those those other losers
this one started to work out then turned
around but you got a you know you got an
indication here in the order flow that
it's not working out here is you know a
ratio and you got a quick little move
lower and then going sideways you know
once a move starts happening then goes
sideways I'm always worry that it's
going
to you know not not work out you know
here you get the sell you get short then
you get the green bar then you get the
doe you know it's you know even once you
start to get in here yeah you got more
up movement than than down movement you
know then the market pops
up this was a what time is this uh 10:30
this one
failed okay then you get your next
signal boom you know you're getting
short at you know seven and a half seven
you know down the down to the four level
four and a half this was a buy that
failed
there's a cell this is a cell with the
ratio you know and and had a nice move
you know
82 3/4 83 down to 81 81 and a quarter
where you you know it went from ratio
here to ratio here and then you know it
went back up so you know you're getting
two or two
points you know then you're getting two
another two points at least at the
minimum you know people say you know
where's your profit Target well you know
I know where my li limit is I mean my my
loss my stop is going to
be but you know once I'm in a trade and
I see things in the order flow telling
me that hey there could be a little bit
more to it like I see ratio ratio I'm
inclined to want to stay in it you know
I don't want to just bail just right
away this one went sideways and then
failed you know honly I get here I think
it's going to work again and then it
fails
you know I mean trades fail you lose you
do have losing trades yeah here's one it
always start to pop up you get a you get
a ratio which is kind of negative a
negative ratio come back down but we
still didn't you know it's not enough to
stop me out we sort of stop and turn you
know right at this level right a tick
above the low and then you turn it move
right back up you know this one
fails two clock
here here's a buy you know again it's
going from you know 84 up to the 87 area
you know you get a sell just sort of
goes sideways pops up here probably
stops you out a buy that fails you know
a buy that just goes
sideways you go into the cash
close this buy you it's after 3 P.M you
know after the cash close you know it's
you get movements and sometimes you get
you know say violent movements but you
get you know big movements after the
cash close on on lesser volume so I mean
it's up to you if you want to trade you
know outside of the cash hours I mean
you
can okay look at the next day here so
you you can see you know your RIS what
your risk is but you could also see you
know you're getting when it's right
you're getting some powerful moves okay
so this is uh Friday July 1st if I
remember right there wasn't it wasn't
that great a day for trading but still
nevertheless you know 6:00 couple sells
here didn't really work out this one
failed this one
one kind of turned around on you failed
stopped you out uh okay here's a cell
this is 839 it didn't work out this cell
also didn't work out those are two cells
with ratios that didn't work out it's
unfortunate you are days where you know
it's just yeah you every everything you
know everything that that normally works
is just doesn't work is sometimes it's
just due to the market so here's a nice
here's a sell you know came right right
back up within a tick of it and sold off
here this one uh you know sort of went
sideways before coming in and stopping
you out here was a buy you know it's
kind of nothing major you know it did
shoot up and then just went sideways on
you honestly this was
a uh a strange week for trading there's
just a lot of other stuff going on in
the market that uh you know this isn't
something to quantify you know with the
whole brexit vote and oh it's terrible
for the world all oh it's the best thing
that happened for Britain you know and
the market goes up all a sudden
everybody wants to to make trade deals
with Britain um with the UK you so you
know where last week everyone you know
you had Obama saying oh you know
Britain's going back to the end of the
line well you know now everyone's
wanting to deal with the New Britain it
seems so you know stock markets back up
a lot of volatility in the market but
you know things are back to normal again
you know it was funny because you know I
felt that the selloff was big
overreaction but then you know the rally
back covering back everything you lost
was a bit exuberant so what can you do
then here's a nice buy here's a buy
right you know you don't have the ratio
here you got the ratio at the same level
and you know it's gone up from this you
know 91 92 level up to you know 96 97
you know it's a nice a nice move and
that was it for the week on the snps so
I mean you can see you saw all the
trading days for the week and and you
see you know the winners the losers you
know you could decide for yourself if
it's something you could add to your
trading okay uh we real quick since I
got some time I'm going to show you the
crude oil this is uh the hugus contract
this is a wrinkle uni Rinko chart and on
this on this chart I've got two
indicators I've got the price rejector
and the Delta scalper and it's a normal
bar chart so you can see how these
things work on on normal bar chart now
the Delta scalper are is going to be
these triangles the up triangle for a
buy and a down triangle for a sell and
also it draws out a support level for
you so you can you know see if this is
going to hold as support you know often
times you know when the Delta scalper
basically reads the Delta for you the
Delta is the difference between the
volume traded on the bid the volume
traded on the
offer and you know positive Delta
generally you have an up move negative
Delta generally indicates a to move but
there's more to it than that um but you
know the Delta scalper is another order
flows indicator now when you get the
order flows Trader software
package the Delta scalper and the price
rejector are additional indicators that
you know if if you just have the order
flows Trader you can read the stuff by
yourself you don't need these indicators
the indicators were designed to make
make it easier for people but you know
if you can read the order flows yourself
then you know great but if you if you're
trading a bar chart and you want to add
order flows into it you can use the
indicators although I do think you know
you can
trade on the order flows Trader chart
footprint chart with the Delta scalper
and the price rejector and you know I I
think it's perfect uh perfect
combination so again crude oil August
crude uh we'll just go through these
indicators for the week uh you know I'll
start around 6:00 a.m. 5:00 a.m. you
know it's a wrinkle chart so it's uh a
little bit different than a than a
footprint chart it's more of a bar chart
so here's a buy this is a Delta scalper
know yeah it sort of went up you know
had a nice up move then sort of hung
around you know up again off up
again
and you know I'll get people they'll see
this chart and say well this trade
wasn't that good because you know down
here it sold off well you know what it
rallied here from 55 up to you know 75
once twice third time you know if you're
not getting out here at
75 by this third time and you're you're
waiting for it to come down and it stops
you out down here you really shouldn't
be you know you should reassess whether
you want to trade or not because you
know you're not making good trading
decisions um you know but I I do get
people sending me charts saying hey you
know I got stopped out down here why
well you had all this time here was in
the money and and you're not taking your
profits you know this is you're getting
in at 750 and you're holding it until
9:30 9 you know
10:00 is you
know you shouldn't be trading on on a
shorter term chart you should be trading
on a longer term chart and you're
stading on a shorter term chart then you
should be getting out sooner rather than
than later you know it's not you buy it
and you hold it until Infinity until you
know it goes and it makes $10,000 I mean
come on I mean but you know some people
do some people do I mean you know
there's and then you know then they get
upset that they lost money
but uh you know I think they should
reassess their whether they should be
trading or not I mean I don't want to
sound negative but you know I mean
people come to the markets and they
think hey you know trading is easy
trading is not easy you know some of the
sharpest Minds in the world are
attracted to the markets and they lose
money you know it's I mean that's just I
would unfortunately you know not
everybody is going to be a successful
Trader yeah we would like all to be
successful but not everybody can be
successful you know sometimes people
have what they call fatal flaws that you
know no matter what they do they they're
going to fail at something so anyway now
this was a buy know you had to have
gotten something out of this trade at a
bare minimum you know at least a
tick if if you think oh this is a losing
trade because you know you got a Buy
Signal here and look it's sold off later
I mean come on they spent a good hour in
your
favor and that was the only one for that
uh for that day you know you had one
signal that day and is a decent one uh
you just go forward okay this is the
price this is the Delta scalper again
it's 530 I don't know if you want to be
trading at that time you can um 5: in
the morning you know it's sort of the
old the IP hours still so you know Bren
crude is is you know available for
trading and you know it's there is some
arbs you get some decent moves again
this was a nice move you know this one
failed um then you got this next signal
here at 9:00 this is the 28th of June
you know you're getting short somewhere
around here 70 4870 40 sorry
4768 you know this is a nice move I mean
look at that it's just straight down no
basically no no reason to be getting out
of this trade you come down here you got
the Delta scalper buy this is at 47
below 4700 so you know if you can't get
at least 5050 50 cents out of this move
you know here is a little different here
you're getting a smaller move but you
know this one is really where's the
green where's the green bars you where's
the what's the market you know is it
telling you to get out here it no is it
telling you to get out here no you know
you start stringing together some green
bars you know yeah maybe down here you'd
be looking to get out because you got
two bars in a
row but you know it's just all red you
know why why you getting out here why
you getting out here yeah you shouldn't
you should be getting out once you're
seeing once the Market's telling you
something something else but you know
but that's a nice move you know
4765 4760 even you know that's a 60c
move then you get a Buy Signal here and
boom you know basically you know
straight up you know another 25 cent
move you know H I would have gotten out
here you know not up here i' I'd love to
see yeah I got out here once I see three
you know three red candles you know I'm
usually looking to bailout okay this is
the price rejector is this hash the
arrow is the Delta scalper the hash line
like here and here is the price rejector
this one failed then you get another Buy
Signal shortly thereafter and you know
it's a nice move from the 65 area up to
you know the '90s even even higher up in
you
know Call It Whatever um you know call
it just you know getting in at 60 out at
90 Sor that's not 60 what is that that's
about 70 you know it's good 20 cents
you know I think could gotten more but
you know I'm not going to claim it um
okay what is this this is the 29th of
June this was you know a nice buy here
yeah it kind of stopped you out I
honestly I would have been stopped out
of
this here then boom okay it's 9:30 it's
Wednesday you got the numbers coming out
the inventory numbers so you're trying
to you get a signal here I'm not one to
trade J numbers
just because you know I I know sometimes
the volume isn't that great but you know
if you got the balls and you like to
trade during that time you'd been amply
rewarded rewarded you know that's almost
a that's a dollar move from from 4830 up
to
4920 okay 90 cents someone say it's not
a dollar but whatever so even if you
didn't trade this and you miss this
whole thing and you're kicking yourself
because you it did happen initially
pretty quick here this is 9:30 it's like
9:30 and 3 seconds if I remember right
and if you're trying to buy or something
you realistically you're buying
somewhere in in here um you know towards
the later the later
part you let's say you know say you
don't want to trade during that number
and you missed this trade okay that's
fine you just you wait you know wait
here you get another sell signal boom
it's a nice little winter yeah it's not
as nice as this big up move and here you
got a couple
cells in
succession you know this is you know 15
down to 90 that's you know this is a
what do you want to call this you know a
10cent move this is 15 cent 25 cents
this one
failed okay and then you know then that
was it for the day so on let's move on
to the uh 30th okay well that's in the
evening session 2: in the morning you
know it's debatable whether you want to
be looking this day I remember was a bit
trickier um you know buy that fail to
buy started to work started to come down
you know again
if you're buying here then got red red
red you know usually after two Reds I'm
already thinking it's going to stop me
out you know here you got shoot St then
you got red red red yeah do I need it to
come all the way down to stop me out
down here after after three Reds I'm
more inclined to just just to try and
get out here you can get out at at a at
you know a smaller loss than letting it
come to to your stop price this one just
you know started then failed
immediately this one didn't work out you
know this was a this was a tough morning
you start out the day with for losing
trades and then boom you know so you
know let's let's you know look at this
real quick let's analyze it uh you know
say
you're getting short here okay let's say
even here
oops you know and you have your stop up
here what is that hey that's not giving
me the right numbers um
uh what is this
here okay
so so yeah okay that's five ticks here
so you know say you're getting short
here and you have you know use it a five
tick stop I me just make sure
um I use that ruler but I'm not the
wrinkle charts it's it's a bit goofy
sometimes but okay crossair so say
you're getting
short you you say you get short here
this is a
sell you know
75 you know where's your stop going to
be you know somewhere up in here 75 82
okay so you know what are you talking
you're talking this the
seven uh what is that seven uh seven
ticks you know and that's being very
generous okay that's getting getting
short here and having your stop way up
here okay way past this this area so you
know four four losers in a row so you
know what is that 7 TI * 4 that's uh 28
28 cents okay well now you got a buy
here this is the price rejector giving
you a buy okay it'll be very generous
we'll still call it make the math easy
4865 you know all the way up to you know
into here 4,900 4905 say you get out
here how many ticks is that 65 to 05
that's 4 tick so you know on this one
trade assuming you just got out in here
because you got three red bars going
down you you made it all back on on one
trade you know I really hate to try and
get everything back on one trade but you
know with these you know orderflow
indicators you can e you know usually
it's going to take me two or three
trades to get back you know my losers
not necessarily one trade it's nice when
it happens you know this one fails
immediately this one you know it shoots
up and then you know starts to come down
so you could have got something out of
that trade okay and that was it for the
day you know you had more losers than
winners you only had about two winners I
I remember but you know you had a nice
one yet that the nice winner was was was
nice you made up for
everything and let's look at
Friday July 1st okay 8 o'clock April 6
whatever
4805 you know goes up into here you got
three down bars you know yeah probably
be looking to get in here that's quick
30 points yeah you know I'd love to say
you just buy here and you get out you
know up here at the High I mean how many
times do you see you know people trying
to sell you indicators say yeah you you
buy here you sell here I mean come on be
realistic you know you're getting along
in here and then you get you know three
Down Candles three red candles that's
really where you're going to be looking
to get out somewhere in there because
you know you see the market just going
sideways now again I'm not saying you
you know you're going to be holding it
from here all the way into here here but
you know realistically you'd be looking
to get out somewhere in here this is the
really the first sign that you should be
getting out yeah later it turned it and
went up but you know honestly this is
where you'd be getting out you know so
you you're getting in at around this
4,800 4805 level and you're getting out
somewhere around
4840 and anything else that day uh had
this one sell started to work turned out
this was late in the day and then know
that was it for the day so you know two
trades One winner one nice big winner
one you know one
loser you know you're getting short
somewhere around here 4875 and then your
stop is up here at you know 4880 you
know somewhere up in here so you know
you had one winner for how many ticks
you know 30 ticks 40 ticks yeah one
loser for five ticks I mean you know you
should be happy with that I mean some
people want every single trade to be a
winner you know they don't want to see
this but you know what that that happens
you know and even going back to this
this previous
day you know people are going to see
this and they'll send me this chart okay
oh look at this this this failed yeah it
it did
fail okay but you know that's part of
trading you know but you got to stick it
out you know because this is you you got
to you got to risk you know trading
involves risk you got to take risks
and you know yeah you're going to lose
here you're going to take risks and lose
but you're going to be rewarded
eventually okay so you know again just
to recap you know the price rejector the
old flows Trader charts and
the Delta scalper they all run on the
ninja Trader trading platform you can
download Ninja Trader for free you don't
need a paid version uh you know paid
version is good to have especially if
you're going to be trading through ninja
Trader brokerage you'll get very low
commission
rates these indicators the price
rejector and the Delta scalper that you
saw also uh they work on the orderflows
trader chart as well as normal bar
charts that's why I showed you the ranco
chart and I think honestly you get the
most out of it you should use the order
flows Trader
charts and it will work on you know
these will work on just about every
Futures market and time frames I mean
day intraday I mean don't don't think
you're going to use an order flow chart
or Delta scalper on a daily chart or a
monthly chart because it won't make any
sense you the order flows you're reading
the order flow as it comes into the
market so you're not going to be trading
very long term uh I I do know people
that trade orderflow using a 30 minute
chart but they they're more of Swing
Traders so it can be done um you know I
think you have to understand the markets
better first before you before you can
accomplish that I mean I don't think a
new person can come in and start swing
trading uh swing Trader generally swing
Traders are are more experienced and
they understand risk because there is
more risk with swing trading because
you're going be holding a position for a
longer time if you're you know a shorter
term time frame
Trader you know you're holding a trade
for a minute 5 minutes 10 minutes 30
minutes max so you know take all that
stuff into account now if you're
interested in the software you can email
me Mike at overflows I'll give you a
special deal um you know for everything
so you know my email is Mike at
orderflows doccom or you could just go
to my website www. orderflows
docomo at Price
rejector www.pr rejector dcom
or you can what am I doing um you could
go to uh
www.d Delta scalper so you want to learn
more about the Delta scalper go D can't
type go to deltas scaler.com
and you can you learn more about all
these indicators again um you know I
think orderflows trading order flow
trading is probably the best way to look
at the market I mean you know if you're
new to trading you know don't don't mess
around don't spend your time waste your
time trying to reinvent the wheel with
macd moving averages I mean all that
stuff's been tested to death and yeah
you may find an edge short term but
you're not really trading you know
you're really just reacting
to you know an indicator you you'd
rather
have something that's giving you taking
the information as it comes in real time
and giving you decisions that you can
trade off of if you're trading you know
I said you're Ming an average or macd
yeah you're looking at you basically
you're taking price
and distorting I say distorting it
bastardizing it is by a better term you
know and trying to curve fit it to
something that you think works why don't
you just learn to analyze the market as
you know as the data is coming in and
read it and you know that's how the best
Traders trade you know they they analyze
what's happening in the market they
don't
analyze an indicator that's massaging
price action you know or even price
actually just massaging
price uh so you know again you know I
think orderflow is the best way to trade
the market you know I've been in the
markets for 20
years and trust me you know I I know a
lot of successful Traders and I've yet
to I've yet to meet any that are using
averages or oscillators or things like
that now uh that said probably is you
know a small handful of people that are
able to be successful maybe I don't know
I I I
yet to meet one on an Institutional
level you know by institutional level I
mean someone that trades real size you
know someone that's trading in you know
in their den you know once in a while
using averages you know hey great more
power to you but you know if you want to
be successful over time and survive in
this game you really need to know how to
read the market and understand what's
happening in the market so again thanks
for watching this video and you know
I'll see you on the inside bye-bye bye